- You also posted this on TikTok.
You said two of these things
are true and one is a lie.
Okay. So one is change the
definition of boss woman.
Two is Kanye is on your album.
And three is you peed on a stranger's arm.
Well, it looks like Kanye
is not on your album, so-
- He's not.
- When and why did you pee on a stranger?
(audience laughs)
- He's not.
I just use his name
'cause it's a lot of buzz
whenever you drop his name,
it just-
- Smart.
- it just goes viral.
- Yeah.
- That's why I put his name on it.
But yeah, the definition
of boss lady in Brazil,
in the dictionary, was
the wife of the boss.
- Ew.
- Like the man, yeah. (laughs)
And I get it.
I got into a crazy fight.
And now a boss lady is just a boss.
- Yeah.
- Same as the guy.
(audience cheers and applauds)
- Yeah.
I didn't know that.
- In the dictionary.
In the dictionary.
I felt that was so offensive,
you know?
- Yeah.
- But the arm, the stranger's arm...
So there was this guy
I found on TikTok a day
in this city I was going
to perform, and he was hot.
So I sent him a message being like,
"Come over to my concert."
So he came with friends,
but then they got drunk.
And this friend of him was like,
"Stop the van! I need
to pee! I need to pee!"
And I was like, "Okay." I stopped the van.
He was peeing in a tree
and the animal touch him.
I don't know what happened.
The animal did something.
- Stung, bit him or something.
- He got this big bruise,
this big burn thing here, his injury.
And he was so drunk, crying,
and be like, "Ah! I'm gonna lose my arm."
- Oh, my God.
And then he said he heard
if someone pees on it,
it kinda makes it better, stops burning.
- That's like a jellyfish. Yeah.
- Yeah. But it wasn't a tree.
I don't know the connection, but
(Kelly and audience laughing)
he was literally saying (chuckles)
- Oh, my God.
- he needed someone
to pee on him.
And I was getting so stressed.
And I said, "Yo, if you
don't shut the (beep)..."
I'm sorry.
(Kelly and audience laughs)
- "If you don't shut (beep)..."
(audience laughs and applauds)
I said, "If you don't shut up,
I'm gonna actually pee on your arm."
And he said, (gasps)
"A celebrity pee's gonna be even better."
- Oh, my gosh.
(audience exclaims)
- And then I said, "Okay."
- You did it.
- And then I stopped the van.
We went to this,
(Kelly laughs)
back there in the airport.
My security, I was like,
"Make sure he's not looking at me."
And he just put his arm
like this into the seat.
And I got like that.
(Kelly and audience laughs)
And he had his arm here,
and he was looking that way.
And my security was making
sure he was not looking at me.
And I was peeing,
and he was like, "Target the
bone. Target the injury."
And I was trying to target
(Kelly and audience laughs)
the injury.
(audience applauds)
- It was crazy.
- Your aim, it's harder to aim for women.
- But he said, "It went away."
- Okay.
- Solved it.
- That celebrity pee solved it all.
- Oh-ho.
(Kelly laughs)
He said it was only because it was my pee.
- Oh, my God. I love you so much.